so a very specific example then um my
son he's three
i would love for him to get into
brazilian jiu jitsu just like me
which i also got into thanks to you two
gentlemen thank you very much
uh so how do i encourage him without
pushing him
without you know just getting him into
it really
you have to make it fun you have to make
it fun
and it is much better for it to be fun
once a week
then for them to hate it three times a
week the kid that hates it three times a
week and you think i'm doing him a favor
or i'm doing her a favor cause i got her
in there whether she likes it or not
she's three years old bro
the best possible thing you can do
is not make them train jiu-jitsu right
now
it's make them enjoy jiu-jitsu right now
i did not do this well with my kids
i didn't it's horrible when my when my
especially my daughters
my daughter when they were very young it
was jujitsu jiu jitsu
we were doing they were doing jiu jitsu
six days a week
they were like six
and that was that was that was part of
it let me tell you what i did that's
worse
what what's worse is i was like okay
you're also going to compete
because competing makes you better and
it gets worse
because then it was oh when i take you
to compete since i'm the coach
i'm going to put you in a higher weight
class
i'm gonna put you against uh older kids
and you know what if you lose look if
you lose
it doesn't matter because you're gonna
be tougher so
go out there do your best if you lose
don't worry about it it's going to make
you tougher
so my daughters go to compete in jiu
jitsu tournament jiu jitsu tournament
jiu jitsu tournament what happens to him
they get beat they get beat by someone
that's older they get beat by someone
that's heavier
is that fun that sucks
what do i think what does idiot think
oh you're getting tougher and so
by the time they were 10 it was like i
don't want to do any of this crap
anymore
and it got to a point where i was like
okay look this is ridiculous
um i i realized the mistake that i made
and i just had to back off
and and luckily my son made it through
that time period
where he he kept training all the time
and and became
very good at jiu jitsu and and wrestling
but with the girls
i i didn't do it right so
find a good school where the jiu jitsu
is fun
don't force it down their throat let me
tell you one more really quick story my
son had a friend
who was like you know his running mate
and when
he was six years old i said yeah we'll
bring your son to jiu jitsu let him try
it
he tried it at six years old he didn't
like he tried it one time i liked it got
choked into crying
he tried it at age seven hey we'll try
it again didn't like it hated it
tried it at age eight didn't like it
hated it age nine his dad trained his
dad had started training
his he kind of got to look at like oh
that's pretty cool
by the time he was nine and he tried it
he liked it
and he liked it because he liked it and
he was then old enough to make a
decision and want to train and started
training hard and he got
good really quick it it wasn't like oh
he missed those four years of training
they didn't make a big difference is my
point they don't make a big difference
so the most important thing you can do
as a parent
is make it fun for your kids make
working out fun
make jiu jitsu fun make school fun
make these things enjoyable make let
them win you know
put them in positions where they're
going to win and i'm not saying every
time
because you do have to learn how to lose
let them learn to lose when they
occasionally
let them learn to lose when they get a
little older but
make it fun for them that's the key